[Musique]
le procès de l'attentat de Magnanville a
débuté ce lundi devant la cour d'assis
spécial de Paris un homme de 30 ans
comparé seul pour complicité
d'assassinats terroristes kidnapping et
associations de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminels cet individu proche du
terroriste est accusé d'avoir été
présent sur les lieux du crime au moment
des fêtes le 13 juin 2016 un couple de
policiers Jean-Baptiste Salvin et
Jessica Schneider ont été assassinés au
couteau à leur domicile de Magnanville
le terroriste avait été abattu par le
Raid le verdict du procès est attendu
pour le 10 octobre l'accusé encourt la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité le
rectorat de Versailles de nouveau dans
la tourmente après la révélation
d'autres courriers menaçants adressés à
des familles c'est notamment le cas d'un
père qui avait dénoncé des faits
d'attouchement sexuel sur sa fille en
mars dernier l'Académie était déjà dans
le viseur depuis la publication de la
lettre adressée aux parents de Nicolas
l'adolescent victime de harcèlement
scolaire qui s'est suicidé début
septembre à Poissy ce week Charlène
Avenel l'ancienne rectrice qui était au
poste au moment des faits à présenter
ses excuses à la famille dans les
colonnes du Parisien en pleine poli
Gabrielle Attal le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est rendu au
rectorat cet après-midi
la première école de commerce de
Mantes-la-Jolie ouvre en octobre baptisé
manschool of business l'établissement
pour accueillir 180 étudiants les
inscriptions pour la rentrée 2023 sont
encore possibles vous pouvez vous
inscrire jusqu'à début novembre sur le
site de l'établissement 4 BTS et de
Bachelor sont proposés
[Musique]